要的所有的姐妹啊，
都给我听好了，
现在好男人真的需要抢的，
好男人真的是稀缺资源，
好男人真的是你下手慢一点就不在你的碗里了，
以后你们遇到喜欢的就给我问，
上去就给我问你有对象吗？
有什么大不了的，
姐当时年轻的时候就是太羞涩，
姐当时年轻的时候如果有这现在这40岁这股子劲儿的话，
我不知道要谈几个男朋友啊，
当年的时候多少是有点儿不开窍啊，
年轻的时候就是太羞涩不开窍。
你知道我最佩服的人是谁吗？
我跟你们讲过，
我最佩服的人是我大学的闺蜜，
她男朋友航空航天大学的模式，
长得又帅又秀气，
皮肤又好，
她就是跟她男朋友是老乡，
完了之后她们读大学，
在北京嘛，
就在一个火车上，
从江西坐火车回北京，
路上她就见色起意，
就看她男朋友长得白白净净的又秀气啊，
路上的时候就上去就约着人家打牌，
然后呢就认识了，
那会儿还没有微信呢，
那会儿就加电话号码，
就加上电话号码了，
回到北京了之后就约人家吃饭，
约人家来学校玩儿什么的，
3天就把她老公搞定了，
到现在上海买了房子之后，
现在三胎都已经生出来了，
我没见你们真事儿，
我说起她这个事儿，
我就有一种特别佩服她，
当年我要是有她这个做派的话，
我。
在江湖上我跟你说前男友一大把啊，
就有点遗憾啊，
提升自己的战斗力啊，
姐妹们都提升自己的战斗力，
遇到长得好看的，
遇到喜欢的你就上去呀，
你就加他的联系方式啊，
你就约她吃饭呢，
你就约她来玩啊，
就这意思啊，
我跟你说我不骗人的，
我说的就是真人真事儿，
3天给她男朋友搞定了之后，
现在在一起生活那么多年了，
孩子都生了三胎了。